unto this star until they stop
[Music]
kill
hey youtubers it's Charlie so Jessica
Jones teaser finally dropped announced
the release date is gonna be November
20th all the episodes I'm gonna do a
breakdown there just a couple teasers
for the series in this this might
actually just be a longer version of the
title sequence like daredevil had the
the blood red that looked like it was
bleeding down the page and all those
shapes from the series this might be
jessica jones version of that if you
don't know who jessica jones is she's a
super-powered character from the Marvel
Universe that works like a private
detective and at various points in the
comics she's been part of the Avengers
the reason why her story is really
interesting is is because she actually
went to the same high school as Peter
Parker she has super strength she can
fly but when she first tried to be a
superhero it is it went completely
terribly and then the villain of this
series played by David Tennant
the purple man started abusing her for
years and years he has psychic abilities
so he exerted his influence over her it
just abused her mentally for years and
years and years season 1 of this series
will probably be her recognizing her own
self-worth because she's every bit as
powerful as Thor so why isn't she in the
Avengers like you'll learn that in the
first episode a lot of that goes into
the way she thinks about herself but the
birch Street and Higgins Drive signs
that you see that's the intersection
where her business is alias
investigations she was created by Brian
Michael Bendis he wanted to write a
hard-boiled detective story so he wrote
the main protagonist as this washed out
superhero like she's a complete washout
from the Avengers but the cool thing is
is the story in that comic the initial
alias comic that Bendis wrote leads up
into civil war
so obviously Captain America Civil War
coming next year so you'll see some
Easter eggs for that movie in this
series it's just that in the comics she
goes around investigating other
superheroes so naturally she's gonna be
talking about superheroes in New York of
which there are many we see the boos
obviously alcoholic as I mentioned and
then as it bleeds to purple that that's
just a metaphor for the influence that
the purple man exerts on her life but he
completely colors her perception of the
world and very literally controls her
mind
now when her comic book story picked up
she'd already broken free of his
influence but she I mean she was a
little PTSD so we'll see where that
figures into this series I think she'll
pick up in Episode one about where she
picks up in the alias comic like she's
already working as a private detective
but it's not too long after she's broken
from the influence of the purple man the
thing about him though that I think
they're gonna tone this down even though
Netflix tends to be a little more
hardcore it's just that the abuse that
was implied in the comic book is really
bad I mean he really abused her so I
think they'll tone that down just a
little bit but throughout her initial
run in the comics he keeps coming back
into her life to try and harass and
abuse her again it's try and take
advantage of her remember like I said
she's just as powerful as Thor and if
you can control someone as powerful as
Thor you could do some really evil
things so that's that's what the purple
man is trying to do with her trying to
use her to commit crimes now on the
other side of that equation we also have
Luke Cage who's debuting in this series
even though he has his own series that
he'll go on to but they're totally gonna
be a thing when this picks up they'll be
no baby I'm not expecting any kind of
baby anytime soon but in the comics they
end up having a child that grows up to
become Captain America the cool thing
about her though is is that she gets
both of their powers so she's super
strong she can fly and she's pretty much
indestructible now we probably don't
need to say a whole lot about David
Tennant he's prequalified awesome
Krysten Ritter and Mike Colter you know
Jessica Jones Luke Cage I'm interested
to see what they bring to the characters
I think Kristin Ritter's a really good
choice I don't know much about Mike
Colter though when I think of Krysten
Ritter as the Jessica Jones character I
think of a super-powered version of her
character from Breaking Bad like a drug
addict who means well but just can't
seem to do the right thing obviously
that's not Jessica Jones but Jessica
Jones in the TV series will be fighting
a lot of the same demons what about
daredevil crossover I know everybody's
wondering about that so we do know that
rosario Dawson is gonna be on the series
she's gonna be like the night nurse type
character although I think technically
they said that night nurse is a
different character because they want to
use in the movies it's kind of confusing
Jun thinking of rosario Dawson is night
nurse no matter what but because Jessica
Jones is investigating other superheroes
in and around New York we'll probably
hear about the devil of Hell's Kitchen
but I don't know if he'll be on screen
like if daredevil will actually be on
screen and Jessica Jones I think they
did say that once characters did debuted
in their own series they would pop up in
other people's series so don't be
surprised if you actually do see Matt
Murdock and because Jessica Jones is
gonna be like this winter the next
series will get obviously is gonna be
daredevil season 2 but aside from
daredevil picking up where Jessica Jones
leaves off I don't I don't know how
connected season 2 of daredevil will be
to season 1 of Jessica Jones
it'll probably be a lot like the Marvel
movies where they loosely reference
things in the previous movie just to
give you an idea of the timeline
oh it's been six months since we last
saw Jessica Jones for someone with big
superpowers like Jessica Jones she's
actually not that huge of a character
she just she hasn't been quite as
popular as the other Avengers or
anything like that so you guys can let
me know like what are you most excited
about for Jessica Jones I think most
people really just want to see Luke Cage
kick ass but remember Jessica Jones also
has super powers that's gonna be one of
the big differences from daredevil is
it'll be a lot of daredevil stuff with
superpowers super-powered villains and
superheroes just in case you guys
haven't seen it I've already done a
couple of Jessica Jones videos
explaining her history in the comics you
can click here to learn all about that
it just goes a little bit deeper into
her comic book origins and you can click
here to learn all about daredevil season
2 Punisher all that awesome stuff thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you